[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in meiner treffen
will
heute möchte ich euch eine nachspeise
zeigen und zwar mache ich heute ein
weihnachtliches tiere habe ich so und
diese nachspeise gehört zu meinem
weihnachtsbrief was ich dieses jahr
gemacht habe da habe ich euch ja schon
das video dazu hochgeladen das findet
ihr hier und ich werde euch jetzt
einfach mal zeigen was ihr anzutragen
braucht dieses theorem so könnt ihr
natürlich zu jeder jahreszeit machen
ich habs jetzt einfach dieses klassische
rezept so ein bisschen umgewandelt und
etwas spekulatius und sind mit hinein
gepackt damit eben etwas weihnachtlich
wird ansonsten ist es nämlich ein ganz
normales tiramisu und dazu zeigen jetzt
einmal die zutaten und zwar braucht ihr
vier eier 500 gramm mascarpone das gibt
es ganz normal im kühlregal 75 gramm
zucker
ihr braucht etwa 250 milliliter stark
kaffee oder espresso da ich keine
kaffeemaschine habe nämlich einfach hier
so ein kaffeepulver und gibt sehr viel
kaffee in die 250 milliliter wasser so
etwa zwei bis drei teelöffel dann
braucht ihr 40 milliliter wandel likör
oder mandel sirup also man dosierung ist
alkoholfrei mandl likör ist zum beispiel
amaretto das ist alkoholisch dann
braucht ihr etwas zimt für das
weihnachtliche tiramisu und natürlich
kakao und ihr braucht löffelbiskuits und
das heute eben etwas weihnachtlich wird
noch ein paar spekulatius und so erst
werden jetzt die eier getrennt und zwar
möchte ich erst das eiweiß steif
schlagen deswegen gebe ich das mal hier
rein
[Musik]
und jetzt lasse ich das eiweiß auf
höchster stufe immer steif schlagen
[Musik]
und hier gebe ich jetzt noch ein drittel
meines zuckers mit dazu dass es noch mal
durchführen
[Musik]
das eiweiß kann dann kurz auf die seite
dann verrührt ihr den restlichen zucker
mit dem 1
[Musik]
und wenn es dann richtig schön cremig
habt gebt ihr da die hälfte des likörs
oder des e books mit dazu und dann kommt
da auch die mascarpone rein und dann
wird es noch mal schön verwirrt
das war es dann auch dann müsse den
eischnee unterheben
viele machen es auch ohne schnee weil es
dann grimmiger wird aber ich finde dass
kraft mit denen die viel leckerer weil
es dann auch ein bisschen locker wird
und die cremiger trotzdem kriegen
[Musik]
so wird dann ist die creme auch schon
fertig und dann nehmt ihr euch so eine
kleine flache schüssel und gebt dort im
café hinein und da kommen jetzt auch die
zweite hälfte vor mandl sie ihre gute
form an billig hören und dann müsste als
das ganze nur noch schichten ich habe
das hier einfach so eine kleine
auflaufform eine quadratische da könnte
wirklich eine form nehmen die ihre
heimat
ich möchte nämlich in zwei schichten
machen deswegen ist es jetzt so eine
kleine dann nehmt ihr euch die löffel
biscuit punkte ganz kurz in diesem café
und schichtet die da rein
[Musik]
und dann kommt als die hälfte meiner
creme drauf
und normalerweise nehme ich jetzt noch
mal eine schicht bis fit aber ich nehme
ich einfach spekulatius
[Musik]
dann kommt da die zweite hälfte der
krebs drauf und dann muss das da haben
sie erstmal in den kühlschrank so für
etwa zwei bis vier stunden wobei ich es
besser finden wenn ihr das über nacht
können stellt so sieht das tiramisu dann
meine auf ich hatte das jetzt etwas
sechs stimmten im kühlschrank besser
aber natürlich gleich auch noch mal rein
stellen bis zu installieren und kurz vor
dem servieren solltet ihr etwas
kakaopulver steuben uns war eine richtig
schöne dinge klar das reicht nur nicht
und wer möchte dann kann dann eben noch
etwas drauf geben aber wirklich nur
wenig weil das sonst zu 18 schmeckt und
dann ist das meine art er mich so auch
schon fertig das tiramisu solltet ihr
dann nicht zu lange aufbewahren
das heißt wir jetzt an dem einen tag
macht und am nächsten tag gestern sollte
es wirklich auf aufgegessen werden
einfach wegen den rohen eier
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat die genauen mengenangaben
könnt ihr natürlich nochmal nachlesen
auf www.stargebot.de die vorspeise und
die hauptspeise verlinkt ich euch auch
nochmal unten in der infobox dann könnt
ihr doch noch mal reinschauen und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
wird durch eine ganz tolle zeit und wenn
ich das video gefallen hat dann teils
gerne lassen wir einen kommentar oder
geht mit der bewertung bis bald
[Musik]